If your party wins the general elect, right,
and you're quite,
you know, it looks like
you're close to winning the general election.
If your party wins the general election,
are you saying you won't
take migrants that are coming through Italy?
Of course not. We won't.
What we're saying is send them back.
Okay? Simple as that.
Poland is the only country in European Union
which we haven't had even one terrorist attack.
We don't have stabbings.
We don't have rapes.
We don't have all these really dangerous
behaviours from migrants,
illegal migrants.
So our policy is very straight,
zero tolerance.
We build a beautiful wall on our,
on our border with Belarus.
And there's no way anyone would enter Poland.
When you see the data from Eurostad,
not ours, from European Union,
Poland is the safest country in Europe.